welcome the best life 30 your 30 day
journey to creating the best life
possible for yourself you can watch just
this video or if you want to sign up for
the whole series for free and get the
bonus companion worksheets that go along
with this video check out the link in
the description below alright so today
is bonus day number seven and we're
gonna learn how to meditate I meditate
every day
I meditate every day and I do it in the
mornings and I do it for about ten to
fifteen minutes and I think it's
important because it just it it sets me
up for the rest of the day you know it
helps me it's like this like it's like
having an anchor you know it's if I
don't do it I feel like I'm constantly
chasing the day as opposed to being able
to be controlled and dictate the day not
that you're you know calling the shots
on what comes forward but the fact that
I am set and ready for whatever may come
my way you know I have a calmness about
whatever comes my way and the poise and
that comes from starting the morning off
with meditation for me it's really just
just listening to my inner self that
there's that's basically it like you sit
in silence and you just allow these
thoughts to come forward and you get a
chance to observe the self and things
that may be lying beneath the surface
that if you don't have that time to sit
quietly on your own you'll never pay
attention to you know because if you
think about it like the reality is were
paid attention to so many things that
are going on around us we're constantly
taking selfies we're constantly taking
pictures to post on Instagram and all
these other things that we're constantly
observing everything that's around this
but we don't take the time to really
observe what's going on inside of
ourselves and that's what meditation is
for me in 2000 we had a new head coach
that came to the Los Angeles Lakers by
the name of Phil Jackson Phil was just
coming off on with his six championships
with the Bulls and he was really big on
mindfulness a really big old meditation
and it wasn't an option for us so we sit
film room and he turned the lights out
and he would you would meditate as a
group and he teaches mindfulness and it
really connected with me because he was
teaching mindfulness through something
that I was extremely passionate about
which was a game of basketball so it was
told through the lens of this is going
to help you here and so I had this
curiosity about it and that was my
introduction to meditation and then
seeing the poise that we played with the
fact that we can be in a hostile
environment with fans yelling and
screaming and you know pressure
situations and it ended having no effect
on us because we were never too high
never too low we were just in the moment
and felt very secure and who we were and
that was my introduction of meditation I
had a great experience which really I
learned a lot about meditation to his
experience I was I was on a jet ski
I took the jet ski out in the ocean and
I just kind of set and I just let the
current just take me wherever it was
gonna take me and I really saw a lot of
meditation through that moment because I
wasn't trying to control the moment I
wasn't trying to force myself upon the
waves and dictate where I was one of
God's let the waves taking you there was
a lot of peacefulness involved in their
meditation is the biggest gift that I
can give anyone and I would say more
than anything it is whatever reason for
success I've had because it allows one
back to the to use I'll clarify what I
mean is that in your mind there we think
what do you want and the reality is when
you look at the neuroscience and
psychology that there are different
parts of your brain that want different
things and so in the simplest sense
there is the logical part of the brain
that you're conscious of it's called the
conscious and you think you're being
logical and you want to make those
decisions and then there's the
subliminal below the limbic system part
of the brain which is the emotional and
it's not as conscious to you but it has
more of an influence on you than really
the logical
and so they're not aligned and so when
you're experiencing that pain or let's
say the ego right there were two main
things you got an ego barrier and a
blind-spot barrier if you can get past
your ego barrier and you get past your
blind spot barrier you can accomplish
anything because you'll also know that
you don't have to do everything - you
have to figure it out yourself you can
take in from other people the different
ways to approach things in the best
possible way and so the realization that
we all are really struggling with
ourselves and to think which are which
is in control meditation helps to deal
with the alignment of those two things
what is your strategy for dealing with
distractions that's a great question
yes something that is that you've heard
about you've heard about this but it's
that thing like are you willing to go to
where you need to go and get out your
comfort zone the number one thing that
has been able to help me with
distractions is two things one of them
is prayer just taking two minutes to
quiet everything out and talk to God
then the second thing which I was I
can't do this okay
I can't even believe I said that is
meditation meditation if if that's one
thing you'll take away which which from
today it's just go on YouTube and say
10-minute meditation smooth music so I'm
typing anything 10-minute meditation I
gotta go see my girl she's mad at me you
know I'm saying like whatever it is type
it in and and just just really kind of
clear your mind
I believe in I've been trained to have a
goal every time you sit down to meditate
you should really have a goal like for
example when you get in the car put on
your seat belt and start the engine to
dry somewhere you have a destination
right
don't get into cons start driving so the
same way when you sit down to meditate
there should be a destination that
should be something that you're reaching
for what is that goal what is that
purpose it's totally up to you really
comes down to what you use meditation
for in the tradition that I come from
that I belong to meditation is a tool
that has many purposes but the ultimate
purpose in our tradition at least is to
attain self-realization or enlightenment
some people just use meditation for
relaxation to relieve stress for all
kinds of things so you set your own goal
for meditation but the key point that
I'm trying to make is that every
meditation should have a goal and a
purpose once you've set your goal the
method and practice that you should that
you have should be systematic and
practical it should be a clear system on
getting from A to B in your meditation
it should never be random it should
never be different every single day the
practice should be the same take a very
simple mundane example so for example if
you go take a shower before you take a
shower you take your clothes off you
turn the water on you make sure it's the
right temperature you jump in the shower
you get wet you put soap on you watch
the soap ball if you like yourself dry
and then you put your fresh clothes on
you never mix that all up you just don't
do that and you do that same order every
single day so the same way with
meditation as well you figure out the
goal that you want to get to you figure
out a systematic step and process to its
getting there and you do that every day
to me it's not enough to exercise the
body you've got to exercise the mind and
in fact to me the body is but a
reflection of the mind and if I could
only work one or the other the body or
the mind I would choose the mind so
right after I finish working out I go
and I meditate and the reason that I
meditate is I'm trying to strengthen and
build and most importantly calm in my
mind and that's something that I think
people forget about we live in a
fast-paced world we prize when our mind
is racing and it's going fast we're
solving problems quickly but it is
absolutely essential to slow down
sometimes
it's absolutely essential to find calm
not just to find it to cultivate being
calm and when you can do that when you
can go from this hyper strenuous uber
intense activity where you're lifting
weights and you're pushing yourself past
the point of exhaustion past the point
of failure and then follow it up with
calming yourself getting centered
grounding yourself and just letting go
it's a beautiful juxtaposition first it
strengthens your ability to change gears
so that if you find yourself in a
stressful situation you're able to very
quickly change gears into being centered
in being calm and then you can address
the situation as it needs to be
addressed but if you only know how to
amp yourself up to get excited to you
know really tackle something you're
missing the whole other side of the
equation and to get into just a brief
bit of the science as you get amped up
especially if you're getting amped up by
anxiety your prefrontal cortex is
actually shutting down or the prefrontal
cortex is what's in charge of your
higher level cognition your willpower
your higher level thoughts judgment
behavior control impulse control all of
those things are handled by the
prefrontal cortex which is shutting off
as you're growing anxious or when the
fight-or-flight response has kicked in
so if you can learn to calm yourself in
those moments to get the blood flowing
back to the prefrontal cortex again to
maintain control of your impulses your
emotions then you're able to get from
the situation what you want these are
all things that you're able to practice
by doing meditation I get a lot of
questions about how to start meditating
keeping in mind that I had a very severe
allergy to the word and concept of
meditation for a very long time more
than a decade and I've only really
consistently started meditating and
implemented meditating for the last two
to three years this is why I think
meditation can be viewed in a way as
stoic training or in some ways similar
to CBT cognitive behavioral therapy
because the objective is to
help you to observe your state and your
thoughts so that you are less controlled
by them what does this mean I'll use an
analogy that I think was originally
shared with me by Andy pretty comb who
is the founder of something called
headspace which I'll talk about in a
second which is the difference in effect
being say standing out in the storm
getting pelted with rain and hail and
wind and stinging your eyes and so on
being soaking wet or standing inside
looking through the glass at the storm
the latter is meditation the way I've
put it before which is slightly
different it's the difference between
being in the washing machine or standing
outside looking into the washing machine
and when you have that somewhat detached
observer perspective you can just be
much calmer much more appreciative and
ultimately effective I do not think that
meditation causes you to lose your edge
this was a concern of mine and I think
it's a concern of a lot of type-a driven
people but even if it did cause you to
lose saying 10% who cares ultimately
you're trying to succeed and make more
money do all these things build a bigger
business to improve the quality of life
for yourself or others and you achieve
that I think more directly in many cases
by even if you had to take say a 10%
haircut on your edge by improving your
present state awareness by much much
more fifty two hundred percent so let's
jump into a couple of options right so
if you're not a dog because dogs are
always present there
mm-hmm then you need some human tools
one option and this is the way I started
very early on meditating was listening
to one song so find one song that puts
you into a good mood and in the morning
all you're gonna do is sit comfortably
so this could be sitting in a chair feet
on the floor just like this hands in
your lap you generally are gonna want
some type of back support you do not
need a dog chewing on a squeaky toy so I
may intervene
Molly c'mere
than freak out or you can sit like this
which is how I tend to sit when I
meditate so this is not full Lotus this
is half Lotus it's not even half Lotus
it's really just one foot tucked into
the crease of my calf and thigh and then
I'm going to kind of pull the butt
cheeks so that I have a nice little seat
here back flat and then my hands are
either gonna be in my lap like so or I
will actually post my hands on my thighs
like this which can also help if you
have a tendency of slouching to keep
your back straight
alright listen to one song for me it was
we're gonna party like it's 1999 Prince
it's hard to be stressed out worrying
about things if you listen that song
trust me you can pick whatever poison
you like but this was shared with me by
Kamal raava Khan and he suggested listen
to one song doing nothing in particular
other than listening to the song and
breathing and that's three to four
minutes that's it so you could try that
in the morning I am always a believer
and I explore this within myself a lot
how much is the past necessary and I
keep coming to the conclusion that it's
necessary that becoming self
observational understanding I think that
developing a through a mindfulness based
meditation practice is incredibly
helpful because it actually helps us to
fire up our brain in a new way that then
allows for self observation throughout
the day because I don't think there's no
magic cushion there's no magic anything
at the way I say it we can't do
something once and then expect my day to
look different magically because I've
meditated in the morning yeah there are
some games and some peace I mean a joke
you may try meditate in the morning so I
can you know calm my mind yeah we get a
little residual you know carry out carry
away from sitting and meditating but if
I'm not watching myself throughout the
day and if I don't train myself to watch
myself throughout the day to watch my
patterns to watch the thoughts that are
causing those emotional reactions
especially to see when when I'm
triggered just when I'm having a big
feeling about a current event typically
the feeling is really big sits a bowel
the meaning assigned to the event and
the similarity of this now event based
on my past experiences and so there's
always a reason why things are way
bigger than they maybe ought to be
in that moment and then that's where we
dive in and give ourselves some new
either releasing the emotional valve
soothing our own emotional wounds in
that moment not looking outside of
anyone or anything else to make us feel
better at least that's the way that I
view it let's do a two-minute meditation
really fast now it's not meditation like
traditional not think of something how
many of you have something in your life
some unfinished business that's
stressful and so you put it off don't
even try to think about it could be in
your business could be and your personal
life could be a relationship how many
got some at home or at work that needs
to be handled and you put it off because
you're so stressed you got so much going
on who's got something like this can you
think of one specifically awesome if you
don't raise your hand you lie about
other things too but that's okay we'll
talk about later on so here's what I
want you to do on a 0 to 10 if you were
to try to deal with that right now
honestly 10 is totally stressful zero is
not at all where is it tell me the
number say that laughs how many got one
7 or above of stress if you focused on
it perfect cuz that'll help you change
now I'm gonna give you a quick technique
for two minutes they got dozens and
dozens of these but it'll work for most
of you'll you'll see so here's what we
found research has been done on how we
get stressed and there's something
interesting they discovered when you're
born your heart starts to beat that's
birth that's when you're alive I don't
mean born outside I mean inside the womb
there's no brain when your heart starts
to beat what makes your heart beat it
has its own intelligence and it affects
your brain it affects your life it
affects everything when we get in our
head we're dead we overanalyze we look
at things we get stressed out but in our
heart we know the answer so these
researchers did they were nominated for
Nobel Prize because they found that if
you focus on your heart you put your
hands on your heart let's go ahead and
do it put your hands on your heart in
fact if you would we just stand up I
think it'll get more of your body engage
you been sitting so long shake your body
out just for a second here just for a
second if you're at home do the same
right all right now put both your hands
on your heart breathe deep inside your
heart meaning close your eyes if you
would and feel your hands touching your
heart feel the power of your heart and
what we're going to do is for two
minutes we're just gonna get grateful
remember earlier I said you can't the
two emotions that mess this up or anger
and fear they mess up your relationships
they mess up
your financial decisions that mess up
career stuff they make some things with
our kids but when you're grateful you
can't be angry when you're grateful you
can't be fearful so we're going to spend
two minutes of gratitude but we're gonna
focus on a heart because research shows
wherever focus goes energy flows and
when you focus on the heart it changes
literally how your brain functions I
could show you an image of when you're
frustrated and you'll see Iggy's EKGs
that's the electrical power in your
brain in your heart and they're jagged
and they're all over we'll probably put
it on the screen when they cut this but
if you breathe in your heart for two
minutes focusing on three things you're
grateful for they literally become in
sync they round and they're won and when
they're won your heart has the answer so
breathe deep in your heart let's begin
as you breathe deep in your heart feel
the power of your heart feel the
strength of your heart feel the beauty
of your heart what are you proud your
heart has guided you to do with this in
this life or to give or to enjoy or to
love feel the power of your heart it
beats a hundred thousand times a day and
you don't have to do it you don't have
to do anything in fact something loved
you enough to give you this heart at the
very beginning you didn't have to earn
it did you you didn't have to prove
yourself you did enough to prove your
worth something knows your worth and
gave you this gift and call God the
universe whatever you call it but feel
that powerful heart that beats and is
always there for you and has been for
decades and give thanks for it and as
you're breathing in this sense of
appreciation and gratitude we're gonna
take about a minute and a half and focus
on three moments in your life you could
feel deeply grateful for they could be
any three moments it could be from your
childhood it could be from today it
could have been from 10 months ago any
moment that you could step back on that
memory as if you were there and fill up
with a sense of gratitude so right now
I'd like you to think of one of those
moments a magic moment a beautiful
moment from any stage of your life
what's been one of the most beautiful
moments of your life yes so breathe deep
breathe in your heart and step into that
moment that you cherish and
fill up with appreciation with gratitude
with joy and feel yourself going into a
beautiful state as you breathe in your
heart and feel like you're there think
of a second moment now that you could be
deeply grateful for again it could've
been at any stage it could be something
little or big step into that moment
breathe like you were breathing then see
what you were seeing then hear and feel
what you were hearing and feeling then
and fill up with that feeling of
gratitude of a joint and then finally
one more moment that you could feel
grateful for well be a really beautiful
moment of your life you could relive
step into that moment now breathe deep
into it see what you saw hear what you
heard feel what you felt fill up fill up
with love or gratitude or joy and if you
can feel it it feels good make a sound
don't hesitate like a little kid make a
sound that feels good to you just go
make the sound do it again and one more
time and make it even louder
that's awesome now continue to feel your
heart in this gratitude I bet there have
been times in your life where things
happen for you that you didn't make
happen or like a coincidence you went to
go do something you met somebody you
love or do something I let to a career
or friendship
what's a coincidence you're grateful for
that led to something beautiful and what
if life was always happening for you not
to you what if you really believe that
even the pain was a gift because it got
you to grow or change or expand what if
everything was happening for you and now
you're in a really beautiful state keep
breathing in your heart and then to
finish this all you've got to do is rip
end a sentence for me keep breathing in
your heart not your head your heart fill
up with that gratitude and then ask
yourself about that thing that used to
stress you a few minutes ago say all I
need to remember Ali to focus on all
need to do in that situation is what and
trust your heart and knows the answer
that fast
feel your heart all I need to focus on
in that situation all I really need to
do all I need to really appreciate or
feel or experience all I need to focus
on all I need to believe all I need to
do is what and your heart knows the
answer raise your right hand with your
eyes closed if you know the answer if
you know exactly what to do to resolve
the situation raise your right hand ice
and high if you would right now and keep
your hand up as soon as you got it raise
your hand perfect keep your hand up and
then open your eyes and look at the
percentage of people who just in two
minutes have figured out how to solve
what was so stressful if you look around
it's about 90 percent for those of you
that are still there you kind of hang it
on a little bit and for those that are
doing that there other techniques but
did it reduce it yes even fill out so
for you ma'am you didn't which one
didn't raise your hand one of you didn't
raise your head yeah so did it reduce it
for you so where was it and where is it
now I went from a nine to a six so we
could do a second one it was stack it so
what I wait is this is a way in two
minutes you starting to feel stress you
breathe in your heart you focus on what
you're grateful three things and then
you look at the problem and from your
heart you solve it how many got it let
me see shouts how many got it like this
give yourselves a big has beautiful
experience
I think Tim Ferriss and I who Tim as a
lovely ham we've been friends for a long
time
first of all a it was I remember a
couple of conversations about isn't this
edge this like at the at your core you
got a fire in your belly you're driven
you mentioned sort of type a
hard-charging whatever words that you
would associate that you start to
believe your own story that that is what
has created your success and we don't
stop or pause were unwilling to part
with that even long enough to see if
that narrative that self narrative is
true because if we stop that
hard-charging type a a grow you know
undercurrent will we lose a step
what were those two steps well we fall
from the position that we've worked so
hard to get ourselves into I remember
specifically exactly exit and talking to
Tim and he was feeding me this line I
was like all those things you said I
thought the exact and I can only say
what my truth is I can't say what your
truth is Tim but just give it a shot
how about what if you were able to think
about that thing that you thought was
propelling you is actually an anchor
that is the thing that is keeping you
down or small or or at some percentage
of your potential rather than in their
way around try and tell yourself that
narrative just long enough for you to
take a break from your aggro
hard-charging type-a life and you know
there's any one of these types of
meditation I have for this dear Tim and
and I found Transcendental Meditation TM
TM org as one that was sticky for me Tim
you know ended up gravitating to that
same thing and when you are able to make
that switch you realize as I did I think
as Tim did that and when you say switch
me switching the narrative yes what's
the narrative and change your daily
habits such that meditation as a part of
your day-to-day for me it I was quickly
easy to see that oh my god this is
actually it's like a rocket it's like a
booster because now everything around me
is happening in slow motion I don't get
fired up and it was a fundamental change
in the way that I
sort of interacted with the world and I
don't it's like I don't want to preach
meditation because it's not for
everybody if there is just if you read
tools for titans tim's book of course
the number one correlated thing across
all those people some sort of
mindfulness practice now you're ready
yeah I'm gonna be the [ __ ] that says
this for everybody
there you go cuz I'm just taking it from
a neurological perspective you know like
purely from a neurological perspective
because I know what's happening right
you're tapping into the parasympathetic
nervous system you call me down the
sympathetic like it's just it's
biochemistry right so if you believe in
biochemistry then give it a shot I'm a
huge advocate I try not to sell it too
hard because anytime someone's trying to
sell you something it feels you know
feels inauthentic but it's just giving
me a lot of joy Transcendental
Meditation is obviously the most
important thing to do day in and day out
transcending is the key to a better and
better life and this idea is catching on
more and more in the world the
receptivity to Transcendental Meditation
is growing by leaps and bounds thanks to
so many in this room and so many else
others around the world it's really
happening it's built for the human being
and transcending our nervous system is
built to transcend and experience that
unbounded eternal infinite immortal
immutable ocean of pure consciousness
within it's money in the bank meditate
regularly and then the second thing I do
is drink coffee
this is the time you are all locked up
in your homes in your rooms make use of
this time to do meditation
do not miss meditation everyday at least
two times or thrice twice our thighs you
sit and meditate
number one second this is the time you
can acquire more knowledge third this is
the time you can acquire more skills you
know you can learn more languages you
want to learn language you can do yoga
you can do many things that you would do
it in recreational time you would use it
in your vacation nobody asked what do I
do in my vacation you find something to
do you go out now this time instead of
going out for vacation you sit and you
read books there's so much knowledge
watch as you know and the television so
many you know knowledge wisdom is
available and listen to music learn
music you can do a million thing you
know no need no point in sitting and
depress and reading the same old news
again and again and getting more worked
up and you can chat with people there
are so many people who are not happy you
are upset you can uplift them their mood
by talking you know you social media
this is the time to use social media
more and why don't you just slow down
calm down cool down for few days you
have that ability don't forget that you
have the ability to just let go and
relax and do that more people are having
disturbed sleep because of the way they
keeping their minds if you are
in a comfortable state of mind if you go
to sleep the body knows when to wake up
one day it may sleep for this many hours
another day it may sleep for half the
amount of time it's perfectly fine body
needs rest
body does not need sleep restfulness is
not in the hours it is in the drop of
metabolic activity that you have
generally in deep sleep your metabolism
drops approximately 8% you sit for
shambhavi your metabolic activity can
drop up to 24% the restfulness that
you're gaining in meditation is three
times more profound than sleep then one
thing that will happen to you is sleep
water will come down suddenly now I've
got a special bonus clip that I think
you're gonna enjoy but before that it's
time for the best live 30 questions of
the day it's not enough to just watch a
video like this you have to do something
and take action in your life so pull out
your worksheets and answer these
questions and if you don't have the
worksheets yet you can get them for free
by signing up for the series in the
description below here we go
question number 1 when can you try a
simple 2 minute meditation today number
2 how can you fit a 30 day meditation
challenge into your calendar and number
3 what are the benefits you like to see
to know that it's working for you and if
you're doing the best life 30 challenge
with me give me a hashtag best life 30
down the comments as well so I can
celebrate you I never thought I'd do
this meditation creates a natural
environment for the body to heal itself
Michael Edwards Michael said I needed to
do healing meditation now I fully
believe in the benefits of meditation
I believe the science I believe the
people who tell me it works for them but
it never worked for me I've tried
following YouTube videos guided
meditation apps and one-on-one coaching
with some of the best meditation
teachers in the world but I never felt
anything I didn't feel any different
coming out of a meditation than going in
I must have tried 30 to 40 different
techniques from different people because
I believe that it works I just never
found the method that worked for me and
yet the thing that never worked for me
was the very thing my new advisor
promised would heal my broken neck great
all in tell me what to do he gave me
specific music to listen to specific
visualizations to do while meditating
specific instructions on how to position
myself specific instructions on timing
and frequency he followed up with me
regularly and kept sending his support
belief and guidance when I loaded my
messages his was the first one I went to
because at this moment in my life he was
one of the most important people around
me I did the meditations because I
believed in Michel and I believed in
Michel because he told his story again
it comes back to his story his journey
got my attention it got me to do
something that I had never had success
with I stuck with it I did a morning and
evening meditation every day exactly
like Michel had instructed me to do I
didn't miss a single day what was a nice
to have luxury suddenly became a top
priority because I needed to get rid of
this concussion from my broken neck then
I started to heal within a couple days I
started feeling better I still had a lot
of brain fog but I could start to think
again one week later I was able to lead
a workshop for an hour and a half
another week later I could lead my full
three hour workshop two more weeks and I
stopped getting dizzy when I lay down
the broken bone in my neck also healed
was it because of my meditation or just
no more healing I honestly don't know
but I was dedicated to my meditation
because I wanted to heal like Michel had
he told this story and it impacted me
now it's time for you to tell yours if
you want to join the best life 30
challenge and get the free worksheets
click the link right here below me or if
you want more videos on how to apply
meditation to your life check out the
playlist right there next to me continue
to believe and I'll see you there
[Music]